the realm do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of Aegon's
enemies a story we agreed to tell each
other over and over till we forget that
it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
8 video in today's video I want to
discuss some of the ways Game of Thrones
can improve their amazing show in the
final season as I'm sure most of you
know by now Game of Thrones has been
receiving a lot of criticism over the
last few seasons mostly ever since they
did surpass in the books this is
something that I haven't spent too much
time talking about because I really
don't consider myself to be a critic
most of you should know I'm more
interested in trying to predict what
could happen in the show instead of
trying to pick apart its flaws but I
recently read an article published by
Forbes calm and I thought this one was
written very well I believe the person
did a good job at not only dissecting
the problems would Game of Thrones but
also providing some solutions on how to
fix it which is why I wanted to read it
today so if you're interested in
listening to something like this let's
take a listen to what this person had to
say let me know if you think their
criticisms are fair or not so with that
being said let's begin number one stop
thinking like a big TV show and think
like a book if you've read any criticism
of the show over the past couple seasons
and especially of season 7 you likely
encountered someone lamenting the fact
that the show has now sprinted past the
books by george RR martin there are many
reasons to be sad about this though at
least starring the mostly excellent
sixth season I was hopeful that at the
very least we'd get a satisfying
conclusion to the story but season six
for all its flaws still felt like the
seasons that came before it and still
felt like an adaption of the books into
a TV show
puzzling aspects aside the previous
season of the show was mostly quite
enjoyable with some truly amazing
episodes that felt at home in the
universe Martin created despite not
being based on events he had wrote
himself season 7 stopped feeling like a
book adaption almost out the gates some
readers were mad at me for focusing on
the speed at which character
moved about the giant Westerosi map but
this fast travel was just one symptom of
a much larger problem the TV show had
abandoned all the little details that
made it once feel like a novel rather
than a blockbuster TV action show gone
were the interesting encounters on the
road or the sense that there was even a
road now characters could teleport from
Winterfell to King's Landing or
Dragonstone to eastwatch-by-the-sea in a
blink of an eye gone too was that sense
of tension invulnerability that made the
show and books so devastated now that
almost every character in the show has
such thick plot armor even incredibly
stupid plans like going beyond the wall
to capture a white have no consequences
Robb Stark was killed for marrying the
wrong woman and the heat of passion and
breaking his vow to Lord Frey but Jon
Snow can go face the night king again
and this time with just a ragtag band of
Heroes walk out with most of his team
intact indeed almost all the Magnificent
Seven survived though admittedly a
dragon was lost
that was one consequence alas the loss
felt contrived given how bad the plan
was to begin with the biggest death of
the season was arguably that of Petyr
Littlefinger Baelish the mastermind who
orchestrated almost all the chaos that's
overcome the major houses of Westeros he
died getting tricked by the stark
children in a plot that made about as
much sense as your average episode of
The Walking Dead the entire sequence was
easily the worst in the entire run of
Game of Thrones and made every character
involved worse all of this is to say
that the show ditched its commitment to
carefully plotted characters and
carefully constructed world in favor of
your usual TV tropes and reliance on big
action sequences crazy CGI in a flat if
long-awaited romance between Jon Snow
and Daenerys so what should the show do
in season a probably the first and most
important thing I can suggest is that
the writer simply consider the audience
the audience for this show is here
precisely because the show has up to
this point care deeply about the
qualities that made it great to begin
with we don't want stupid Littlefinger
getting duped in a stupid plot if
there's going to be an element of
intrigue it has to be as good
or better than those that came before
what we gut felt like amateur hour think
like a book not a TV show give yourself
the time with each story that each story
deserves even if that means extending
the final season beyond six episodes
face it season seven felt rushed to the
point that where the show was an insult
to both its viewers and the source
material I understand wanting to wrap
things up but let's do it with the
respect for the story that it deserves
even if that means fleshing out the
current scripts and extending the final
season number two remember that even
though this is an epic clash between
good and evil Game of Thrones isn't just
epic fantasy this moves us along to our
next point as much as Game of Thrones
has always been a drama with elements of
action the books were always gritty
medieval fantasy based on historical
conflicts and rooted in a sense of
realism what the show has become his
high epic fantasy with fire-breathing
dragons and evil undead armies led by
wicked magical kings this would be fine
if the rules of the earlier show or
books still applied for instance if we
had characters still acting like
themselves and who paid the price other
poor decisions with some kind of
consequence transitioning from gritty
realism to high fantasy might work a
Song of Ice and Fire was always
something of a deconstruction of the
fantasy genre yet it's largely been
moving toward the same broad strokes
endgame as the show a conflict between
the others north of the wall and their
army of the dead and the forces of the
living including Dany and her dragons
that's gonna be high fantasy no matter
what but one suspects that if the books
are ever finished the high fantasy
tropes that accompany a confrontation
between a Dark Lord in a chosen hero
will be subverted and deconstructed in
some way after season seven of the show
I have less hope that HBO's adaption
will be as interesting or as bold still
season 8 could get back on the shows
earlier sense of grim realism even while
the final showdown between good and evil
takes place there are plenty of fan
theories that suggest the knight king
may be one of our heroes or that there
might be some terrible betrayals in
store for our favorite characters if
handled properly these ideas could
result in a show that still surprises us
but I think these big twists and reveals
betrayals still filled - gotcha for a
story such as this rather I'd like to
see the characters natural tendency
served to both undermine them and
surprise us in more natural less big
twists big prophecy ways looking back on
Robb Stark's character arc his downfall
was never because of some prophecy or
because he was special in any way he
didn't need to be the true heir to the
Iron Throne or the mother of dragons
he was Ned's son taking up arms to save
and then to avenge his father and he
died because he was foolish and horny
and romantic and young Oberyn Martell
died because he liked the sound of his
own voice to much any underestimate in
his opponent the show in the books were
always better when they dealt with
normal people and exceptional
circumstances either overcoming their
obstacles or being crushed by them that
should not change now just because we're
at the endgame number three don't ignore
the world-building just because we're at
the endgame doesn't mean that the
world-building should suffer but it has
this is partly due to the after
mentioned fast travelling which robs
viewers of most of the show's best
moments which almost all take place on
the way to and from places context is
important and when Westeros feels like a
big huge dangerous place it felt real
now it feels like the size and scope of
the world have become diminished to
something much smaller and safer and
less interesting or take Highgarden
referred to as one of the richest and
most beautiful cities in all of the
Seven Kingdoms the show gave us quite
literally the least interesting least
beautiful Castle we've seen so far
or take Dorne its leaders were killed in
season seven but the show seems to think
that that would mean no other leaders
exist in Sunspear it's a prosperous land
in the only in the Seven Kingdoms where
it's later could be called prince rather
than Lord many thousands of Spears
staying ready and waiting to a Daenerys
because house Martell and House
Targaryen have a long friendship yet the
show simply wipes the entire region off
the mat with a Lauria in the sand snakes
death or imprisonment all of this
diminishes the world that both the show
and author have so painstakingly created
they've done this before as I pointed
out what the Dornish ku but also in how
they've treated other characters deaths
the monumentally terrible death us are
Barristan Selmy was another moment that
diminished the world and so was the
pointless reintroduction and murder of
OSHA and Rickon but it's gotten so much
worse in season seven when it comes to
the a season I urge the show's writers
producers and directors to never forget
how important world building is to a
story like this don't gloss over the
small details don't forget about the
rules already in place don't ignore
entire regions in order to expedite the
storytelling these things are what make
the show not merely good but truly great
oh and give us ghosts ghosts is more
important to the story than the
showrunner seem to believe number four
don't expect the audience to be okay
with gaping plot holes Thrones fans are
smarter than the average bear
expectations matter who your audience is
matters I truly never expected Game of
Thrones to ever remind me of The Walking
Dead what season 7 was a whole different
story
the fake-out subplot in Winterfell was
just incredibly cheap it was weak
writing plain and simple
that was less about telling a good story
and more about fooling the audience well
the audience rarely likes to be fold at
least in such a cheap way or take your
own Greyjoy's magical fleet a thousand
ships miraculously built in just months
that can zip around Westeros at great
speed and never fail in battle their
plan to go and catch a white beyond the
wall was quite obviously very stupid and
simple alternatives presented themselves
to just about anyone who took the time
to come up with them likewise the speed
of the Ravens and Gendry and Daenerys
was called into question not because
there's no possible way that this could
have worked on screen but because it was
so loosely thrown together it felt
incredibly lazy
in the discerning viewership of Game of
Thrones felt insulted by it in season
eight the showrunners need to make
absolutely sure that three things happen
characters must act in character at all
times and suffer the consequences of
their actions both good and bad time and
distance has to be accounted for and
conveyed even if it isn't a major part
of the story stories cannot exist merely
to move the plot forward or to trick the
audience they have to flow organically
from the characters if the writers stick
to these concepts we should
in season eight no more cheap tricks and
no more inexplicably stupid moves
Ontarians part in at least some nod to
the distance traveled and the time
passing this last thing can be achieved
easily through snippets of dialogue in a
bit more run time rather than such
abbreviated seasons number five read
over the dialogue a few more times
before you film it a mine needs a book
as a sword needs a whetstone if it's to
keep its edge never forget what you are
for surely the world will not make it
your strength then it can never be your
weakness armor yourself in it and it
will never be used to hurt you the
things that we love destroy us every
time lad remember that what is honor
compared to a woman's love what is Duty
against the feel of a newborn son in
your arms or the memories of a brother
smile wend in words wind in words we are
only human and the gods have fashioned
us for love that is our great glory in
our great tragedy these are all lines
from Martin's books if he hadn't guessed
already they are at times peppered into
the show as well it's why the dialogue
is often so good in this show it has
such great source material but I don't
accept that Martin was the only reason
the show had good dialogue in its
earlier seasons there were scenes as far
back as season one that never took place
in the books that were incredibly
well-written what dialogue that fit
beautifully alongside Martin's
but season 7 all but abandoned even a
pretence of actually caring about
dialogue Jon Snow delivered the same
speech countless times when we learned
of the prophecy of azor Ahai we were
literally clubbed over the head with the
fact that it could be referring to a man
or a woman tyrion seems to has lost his
wit entirely in Littlefinger of course
well you get the picture take some time
with season 8 give us dialogue that's
every bit as interesting as the story
once was this might be a show about
fire-breathing dragons but that's never
been the point this is a show about
interesting conflicted complicated
characters interacting with one another
more often with words than with blades
I'd say a story needs words like a sword
needs a whetstone if it's to keep its
edge all right so let me know what you
think about what that person had to say
do you agree that
these things could help fix the show in
the final season or do you believe that
the show is just fine the way it is in
my opinion I pretty much agree with
everything that was said in the article
as much as I do love the show I came
tonight a fact that the overall quality
of the story has suffered since they
went off course of the books now don't
get me wrong
Game of Thrones still operates like a
high quality show the costumes the
cinematography the action sequences the
CGI and the score are all still amazing
however the writing and the pacing has
definitely suffered especially during
the last season I think one of their
biggest mistakes was trying to shorten
each season I mean I understand why they
did it because it does allow them to be
more flexible with their budget but I
also feel like this has cut the legs out
from underneath the show but regardless
of what people think about the previous
seasons I am still holding out hope for
the final season I do have faith that
they can deliver something satisfying
for the viewers but I also highly
recommend that the producers and the
writers of the show take some advice
from some of the criticism they have
received it's never too late to turn
everything back around and I do hope
that they can fix some of the issues by
making each episode a little bit longer
in length which they did say they were
planning to do leave your thoughts down
below in the comment section let me know
what you think they can do to make Game
of Thrones great again anyways I hope
everyone has a great day and for those
of you that celebrate the holidays I
want to wish you a Merry Christmas and a
Happy New Year's thanks again everyone I
will see you again very soon bye
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
you
you
you